Kevin McCarthy as well speaker of the
house is floating the prospect of
impeaching Biden rising to the level of
impeachment inquiry which provides
Congress the strongest power to get the
rest of the knowledge and information
needed because this president has also
used something we have not seen since
Richard Nixon use the weaponization of
government to benefit his family and
deny Congress the ability to have the
oversight I believe we will follow this
all the way to the end and this is going
to rise to an impeachment inquiry the
way the Constitution tells us to do this
and we have to get the answers to these
questions what do we mean that Richard
Nixon we haven't seen the weaponization
of government like this since Richard
Nixon Barack Obama wielded the
government agencies against his
political enemies all the time this has
been a pattern that we've seen on the
left it's been done on the left way more
than it's been done on the right and
that's not even the reason that this
meets the the standard for impeachment
we've got evidence of corruption